from piano sing-alongs food and drink
specials to giveaways and contests the
new york new york hotel doing it big for
st
patrick's day rocky theist joins us live
from our very own brooklyn bridge with
all the details hey rocky
hey kirsten yes okay we've got drinks
we've got parties and we've got
live music because you can't do saint
patty's day without a band right so i'm
here with jason he's the director of
beverage you've been busy
director of beverage on st patrick's day
is a big job yes
very big job yeah so as you can see here
we have our live entertainment stage
which live entertainment will start
tomorrow
10 a.m to midnight so it's live
entertainment all day
so can you give us a sneak peek on what
bands will be playing no sneak peeks oh
come on okay this is this is the most
you're gonna get you guys so this is
your exclusive you gotta come down to
the brooklyn bridge here at the new york
new york
first of all this is just really cool
this is really cool so what can people
enjoy here on the bridge
yeah so this would be one of our two
beer gardens okay
you'll be able to enjoy traditional
irish fair
guinness which everybody loves a nice
draft of guinness
um yeah
again irish food dance well no dancing
but
again live entertainment if you want to
do a little irish dancing you could you
know
yeah as long as you're socially distant
exactly so now now that you mentioned
let's talk about how we can celebrate
safely here at new york new york
yeah so we encourage you know if you're
local
come down see us if you're vacationing
here stay an extra day and enjoy it with
us
but again just remember masks are
required and socially distancing will be
in force
okay and besides the brooklyn bridge
celebration we also have a lot going on
on the inside too tell us about the
other locations people can enjoy
uh so we also have the arcade the roller
coaster which
new york new york is so cool famous for
but on top of that our big activation
for the week is going to be our pepsi
wild cherries activation so here
guests can come in um and what we can do
what they do
is they show their wild side so if they
can enter
a contest to win ten thousand dollars uh
by doing that they would go into a video
booth
show their wild side safely um and
post it on instagram and they're entered
into the contest i love that idea that
is so cool so so jason you know we've
got a couple seconds here you want to
show us your wild side on
i'm kidding you will see that tomorrow
come back and see me
i like this guy thank you so much jason
i've had so much fun here at new york
north actually and just to be honest
this is my first time here and i'm
impressed
well you got to come back and see me
tomorrow absolutely all right thank you
so much we'll send it back to you
so much fun there thanks so much rocky
we greatly appreciate that
always a good time with rocky in new
york new york you can't beat it